there are so many news reports now on
rampant crime in major cities that at
this point you can't be blamed if your
eyes glaze over when you see them there
are only so many clips of thugs
shoplifting doing Street takeovers or
shooting at cops that you can watch and
at some point even though it's it's
horrible you get numb to it but one
recent report from CNN on property crime
in San Francisco stands out we played
part of this clip a couple of weeks ago
on the show but here it is in full
context watch
San Francisco businesses fed up with
crime one sandwich shop owner is calling
for action after he says he was attacked
outside his store he says he yelled at a
man to stop urinating on his trash can
and then we sucker punched his Instagram
post about the incident has now gone
viral
I'm fed up with this city it's like
I can't just be outside and just running
a business without getting punched in
the face it shouldn't be this way at all
like this isn't how our city should be
now it's not clear what we said before
the altercation or whether there's even
video of it but San Francisco police
have said they are investigating it
comes as some stores are locking up
everything from coffee to frozen food to
try to combat theft Arc young law
visited one Walgreens that's hit by
shoplifters more than a dozen times a
day it happened three times while she
was inside
Richard Greenberg walked into a San
Francisco Walgreens when he saw in the
frozen food section this chains heavy
chains that went from padlock to padlock
on both sides of the doors and this was
bizarre something I'd never seen before
this is just
icing on the cake
telling us that rampant crime is is has
become a regular part of life so typical
that in the 30 minutes we were at this
Walgreens
okay
we watched three people including this
man steal did that guy pay
did that guy pay
he didn't pay
so this Walgreens is supposedly hit by
shoplifters more than any other
Walgreens in the United States which is
really saying something the bar is
pretty high to achieve that record
people are walking in and out with with
merchandise at will without paying
shoplifters robbed the store three times
while CNN was inside reporting on
shoplifting as I said you've seen
portions of that clip when it went viral
several weeks ago we played it on the
show but we never played the end of that
segment and here it is
San Francisco city supervisor Matt
Dorsey former police spokesman and
recovering drug addict sees the rampant
shoplifting as a systemic problem from
city leaders to an understaffed police
force to the fentanyl crisis when you're
seeing that level of retail theft that
tends to be subsistence level retail
theft people who are hungry people are
hungry there is a level of addiction
playing out in many parts of our city
it's happening at levels we really
haven't seen in San Francisco what I'm
hearing from my residents and what I'm
hearing from San franciscans is it's
time for tough love we are not doing any
addict in this city favors by enabling
behavior that is potentially deadly in
ways we have never seen
now in a statement to CNN Walgreens says
it is focused on safety and preventative
measures but that retail theft remains
one of its top challenges here's some
important contexts though on the city
Aaron property crime and violent crime
at the end of last year was actually
lower than it was before the pandemic so
what's going on here
so first CNN trots out a city supervisor
to inform you that the causes of all
this shoplifting are systemic you know
it's sort of like racism in that way
he's implying there's no way to solve it
but of course you should pay a lot of
you know consultants and government
agencies a ton of money to try to solve
it even though it can't be solved
because it's systemic that's what every
bureaucrat means when they talk about
systemic problems uh systemic problems
is really that's just a job Pro jobs
program for for bureaucrats in other
words and then the CNN reporter comes
back and she says that she's providing
some important context and what is that
context well she says that property
crime in San Francisco is lower than it
was before the pandemic in other words
as bad as the footage you just saw might
look overall the city is doing fine the
ice cream sandwiches might be uh locked
away with chains and people are so
Brazen about stealing that they're doing
it in front of news cameras still the
city is on the right trajectory
everything is fine nothing to see here
that's the message
now in the world of Statistics they have
a few terms for this and one of them is
non-response bias another is measurement
bias
so if you're looking at a chart of
reported property crimes and it goes up
and then up and up and then suddenly it
goes down out of nowhere a couple of
things are possible the first
possibility the one that CNN implies is
happening here is that people are
committing fewer property crimes somehow
the criminals have decided on their own
to stop doing crime
even though they know they can easily
get away with it they decided to just
stop doing it they've decided to become
law abiding citizens uh out of the
goodness of their hearts their hearts
have all grown three sizes like the
Grinch when he visited Whoville
the other possibility though is that
maybe people have simply stopped
reporting property crimes because they
know the police and the D.A won't do
anything about them
could that be happening in San Francisco
despite the city's property crime
statistics is it possible that property
crime is actually increasing
Dick's Sporting Goods just provided
another data point to help us answer
that question Dix has locations all over
the country of course and they just
announced that property theft theft is
costing them so much money that they're
now laying off a mass number of
employees the company says that profits
dropped 23 percent last quarter which is
a staggering amount
and they blame much of it on rampant
shoplifting
so when you hear that property crime is
going down and then you see stories like
that you have to wonder whether the
statistics give you an accurate picture
especially when dicks is far from the
only chain that has had to shut down
locations lay off employees
because they keep losing so much
merchandise to theft
it's kind of like when influenza cases
started to uh it went down basically to
zero during covid
is that because as the experts said
influenza simply just stopped spreading
somehow during the pandemic
that's a comforting explanation so it
mainly went unchallenged
and most statistics from the government
are like this they're technically
correct but wildly misleading
however one government statistic is very
tough to fudge no matter how hard
politicians try and it's the murder rate
you know the government can lie and say
that shoplifting is down but it's
challenging for them to lie about
murders because murders leave dead
bodies people talk about them I mean
they usually get reported
Corners have to be dispatched to the
scene and so on
between 2019 and 2020 the homicide rate
in the United States increased by more
than it did at any other point in modern
history went up by 30 percent
following year it increased again
some of the country's most prominent
tourist destinations have become too
dangerous for many people to visit last
year for example New Orleans became the
murder capital of the United States
recording 52 homicides per 100 000
residents
now browse news reports on the violent
crime wave in this country and
invariably uh you'll hear the same
excuses they'll tell you that covet is
responsible for the murder rate they'll
do what the San Francisco city
supervisor did and blame systemic issues
like policing
what they won't do is tell you that
actually
a real and immediate solution to this
problem is available
in El Salvador under the leadership of
Naye bukeli they have figured out a
solution in 2018 the year before
buchelli took office El Salvador posted
a murder rate of 51 per 100 000 people
which is the New Orleans rate
by 2022 the murder rate in the country
had fallen to 7.8
per 100 000 people that's 7.8 not 78.
this chart that we have a chart here we
can show you that shows the magnitude of
the decline you can see that the murder
rate was decreasing before bikeli took
over but he took it to an unprecedented
low level
I mean this this is a a homicide rate
now in El Salvador that's significantly
lower than what you'll find in several
major American cities
and these are not cooked numbers okay
you know that because naive bouquelli is
overwhelmingly popular in El Salvador
people know that murders are down they
know that they are safer in their
communities because they live in these
communities they don't need the
government to tell them about it
El Salvador accomplished this massive
reduction in homicides if you can
believe it
by doing something radical they decided
to start punishing criminals
specifically but Kelly implemented
something called the territorial control
plan and phase one of that plan involved
flooding high crime areas with heavily
armed police officers many criminals
with gang affiliations often indicated
by their tattoos which are often on
their face easy to see went to prison
officials paraded them before cameras in
a humiliation ritual this has been an
integral part of El Salvador's strategy
for years just a few months ago Kelly
uploaded a video which shows gang
members in one of the super prisons he's
constructed to house them kind of
showing you how it works in these
prisons and we'll show we'll play a
quick clip of that here it is
[Music]
foreign
place to be and Al salvad El Salvador's
government has not relented in the past
few years in fact this summer El
Salvador's Congress approved new rules
allowing the trial of up to 900 gang
members simultaneously to expedite the
otherwise slow-moving judicial process
you know before giving our dog rough
greens he was so sad and lazy and now he
actually enjoys his squeaky toys playing
Fetch with his frisbee our pup stays are
filled with laughter exercise and
endless fun and it's so important to me
that he has fun it's the most important
thing in the world to me naturopathic Dr
Dennis black the founder of rough greens
is focused on improving the health of
every dog in America little did I know
before I got rough greens dog food is
dead food everybody knows nutrition
isn't Brown it's green well let rough
grains boost your dog's food back to
life rough grains is a supplement that
contains all the necessary vitamins
minerals probiotics
Omega oils digestive enzymes and
antioxidants that your dog needs you
don't have to go out and buy new dog
food you just sprinkle rough Greens on
their food every day dog owners
everywhere are raving about rough grains
it supports healthy joints improves bad
breath Boost energy levels and so much
more we are what we eat and that goes
for dogs too naturopathic Dr Dennis
black is so confident rough greens will
improve your dog's health he's offering
my listeners a free jump start trial bag
so your dog can try it free jumpstart
trial bag can be at your door in just a
few business days go to
roughgreens.commatical 844 rough 700
it's ruffgreens.com Matt or call 844
rough 700 today
now in some Publications including the
National Review and various left-wing
Outlets you'll find alternative
explanations for how bikelli lowered the
murder rate so quickly in one popular
theory is that all these harsh measures
are not reducing crime instead the
theory goes who Kelly struck a secret
deal with the gangs that convinced them
to stop committing crimes and there's
some truth to that but Kelly did indeed
try to negotiate a truce with uh MS-13
and other gangs but as CNN reported last
year citing an expert in Central
American Affairs quote there are some
consensus among security Watchers the
Kelly's truce with the gangs fell apart
in late March 2022 which prompted the
ms-16 to do The Killing Spree to
pressure the government to give
concessions
so but Kelly's latest Crackdown followed
the breakdown in negotiations and still
violent crime remains low
the Crackdown has saved lives there's no
question about it other Central American
leaders are now looking to model El
Salvador's approach
there's no question about that either
the only remaining question is whether
saving these lives and restoring order
to society and making communities
livable again
is worth a few sacrifices
most notably is it worth sacrificing
some of what we in modern Western
Society consider to be Humane standards
for imprisonment
is it worth sacrificing some of those
standards
in response to that question the media
has answered unanimously in the negative
the Sun for example
just published a lengthy piece lamenting
the conditions in El Salvador's prisons
inmates are crammed together like
sardines the sun says quote in each 100
square meter cell around 75 crammed
inmates sleep on metal cabins and are
forced to share just two toilets and two
sinks
several other outlets have run similar
stories in recent days talking about how
terrible it is in these prisons in El
Salvador how it's all a human rights
violation here's the BBC for example
watch
relatives of those detained have been
desperately trying to find out what's
happened to them
I saw the video on Facebook and I was
going through it pausing and rewinding
he was almost unrecognizable so very
thin I only knew it was him by his
tattoos
Angelica says her husband has no links
with gangs she's heard nothing for
develop him since he was arrested under
emergency Powers brought in in March
2022 by president bukhale
through satellite imagery data released
by The Salvadoran government and
documents seen by BBC Mundo we've
gathered information about the site
there are eight cell blocks monitored by
19 watchtowers
inside the cells the beds are metal
plates and there are two toilets open to
the room
so far the authorities say they have
transferred four thousand prisoners to
the jail and that there is capacity for
up to 40 000.
the BBC has found that at full capacity
each person would have 0.58 square
meters of space the international
Committee of the Red Cross recommends
3.4 square meters in a shared cell
okay so this President does not live up
to the standards of the Red Cross or the
U.N or any Western human rights Watchdog
group it's very very uncomfortable to be
in prison in El Salvador right now so
uncomfortable the fact that it might
even make you think twice about joining
a gang in that country to begin with
which is obviously the point now with
that said we hear from someone in the
clip who claims that at least one of the
inmates her husband has no connection to
gangs he's an innocent man caught up in
the Crackdown caught up in the net
and we have no way of assessing whether
that story is true obviously but we
don't know is this person innocent or
guilty how do we know but if we're being
honest we probably can assume that some
non-violent people even some innocent
people have been caught unwittingly in
this net some of them may be innocent
true anytime the government assumes
emergency powers and arrests more than
70 000 people without ensuring their due
process rights it's bound to happen
and yes it's almost certainly true that
many of these inmates live in conditions
that would make Amnesty International
extremely squeamish
there's no reason to paper over that
but that's not where the discussion ends
or where it should end the question that
follows is a simple one though it's
rarely discussed and the question is
this would you rather have a safe
Society where a few innocent people are
imprisoned or would you rather have a
very dangerous Society where only a few
guilty people are imprisoned
Ben Franklin famously uh answered a
version of the question he said it's
better for a hundred guilty persons to
escape than one innocent person to
suffer
and we hear people repeat this Mantra
unthinkingly all the time but Ben
Franklin didn't address what happens
when all those guilty people get out of
prison and make it impossible for
innocent people to live their lives what
happens when allowing guilty persons to
escape means that innocent people can't
start businesses or use the Subway or go
to the store walk down the street
or guarantee the safety of their
children
what happens when letting the guilty Go
free means letting them randomly assault
elderly people or carjack women at the
stoplight or execute cast station gas
station cashiers for for the few dollars
in the cash register
that's unfolding now in major cities all
across the country
it's happening so often that CNN is
capturing it on camera unintentionally
this is not the high trust society that
existed in the 19th century
when Barack Obama was in office he made
a habit of calling
difficult decisions quote false choices
he said that we should for example
reject the quote false choice between
our security and our ideals
but the truth is that there are hard
choices to be made when weighing our
security against our ideals
this is not a false Choice there are
actual trade-offs you have to make
there's no sense in lying about it
as Richard hanania pointed out recently
on a sub stack sometimes a slavish
Devotion to ideals gets a lot of people
killed and it ruins livelihoods
nobody wants to talk about that but it's
true
and as more criminals act with total
impunity it's getting hard to ignore
besides the other point here is that
nobody can claim that they really have a
zero tolerance for you know for example
innocent people going to prison we like
to say that well we can't we can't allow
those single in this person go to prison
because the only way to bring that
number down to zero is to have no
prisons at all if you have any kind of
prison system there's going to be that
kind of unintended consequence
regardless it's going to happen
and we all accept that tacitly we have
to or we cannot have a civilization
but we're currently in the process of
losing our civilization and it's in part
because modern Western people have a
totally upside down view of these kinds
of trade-offs
or they're so naive that they think that
they're that we can have no trade-offs
but that's not the case you can't get
around it either you emphasize justice
social order and punishing criminals
and you deal with the collateral damage
that comes with this harsher and more
brutal approach
or you emphasize tolerance and
acceptance and Rehabilitation and
forgiveness and you deal with the
collateral damage that comes with that
you will get the collateral damage
either way there's no way around it in
the former case it means that you'll
have a safer and more orderly Society
where people can live their lives and
your children can walk outside without
fear
but criminals will be made very
uncomfortable and will be treated in
ways that are sometimes quite ugly
and in the latter case criminals will be
more comfortable and prisons will not be
such an ugly place
but your communities will be unlivable
cesspools
as I've said before there will be
ugliness in society no matter what you
can choose to contain it in prison or
you can let it loose on the streets you
will have it the ugliness whether you
like it or not the question is where do
you want it in prison or outside your
front door
El Salvador's solution is not ideal I
mean you'd prefer if your country didn't
need to have super prisons with tens of
thousands of violent gangsters in them
nobody would call that an ideal
situation certainly not naive and Kelly
at a certain point though it becomes
necessary because the alternative is
even worse
if our leaders don't have the stomach to
punish criminals now then down the line
they'll be replaced by people who do
that's the lesson of El Salvador we can
either learn from it
or we can keep repeating the same
mistakes
the choice is ours thanks for checking
out this video if you'd like to listen
to my full podcast on the go you can
check out the Matt wall show on Apple
podcast Spotify or wherever you get your
podcasts